you don't need them any introduction
your name is a brand is already a brand
it's a brand for for Innovation for
ambition for a perfume
yes yes this is the agreement that you
made with uh there are no family a few
hours ago I mean it's I mean really it
Brands itself yeah and you are the
origin of people Tesla SpaceX to name a
few and even open AI so yeah
you love taking risks and you are going
always against the tide and the popular
wisdom
you have been always proven right now
there is almost always
now there is a bet
of the 44 billion US dollar question
which is will you still be right with
Twitter sure
uh so it was expensive yeah yeah
I don't know if um
you know listen if I'm so smart why did
I pay so much for Twitter then
[Laughter]
so as I'm not a journalist I'm not
trying to get headlines and to have
provocative
response and to make a scoop but
nevertheless
if you wish to do that
it is authorized okay great so we are
expecting that you will really make the
show because everyone comes here
to see you to listen to you and to get
some of the magic that you have all
right well I'm I'm honored that you
it'll I want to listen to what I have to
say it's uh great to to see the crowd
and uh I know you guys seem awesome so
but you told me that you would like
you said that you would like to speak in
French
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
[Applause]
some people who believe that you are a
genius and yeah there are some who are
you will believe that you are evil so
but I mean you can be both
I mean you could be an evil genius
that's not uh you know so that's what
you are or you will let the people draw
that on conclusion
um uh I am definitely not evil
what
what is the thing that you have ahead of
your oh yes if you look carefully you
can see an angel's Halo on my head and
the wings uh it's a subtle but where are
the wings yeah they're difficult to see
but if you look carefully you know
they're right there yeah yeah small
Wings yes
um
[Music]
um so uh
yeah
um okay so that wasn't convincing you
don't
you have done a lot of operation you
have created a lot of companies the most
important question for everyone is what
the hell is driving you why are you so
obsessed by new operation New Creation
new things to do
yeah crystal meth is the answer
if you think Red Bull gives you wings
um
so
man that that's that that quote it's
gonna probably sting
um
so um
yeah just kidding for the record
[Laughter]
um so well I think there's the companies
still have a lot to do for their their
core Mission
um the you know for electric vehicles
sustainable energy
still less than one percent of the
Global Fleet is electric so you've got
about two billion cars and trucks on the
road but still less than 20 million are
electric at this point so this is a long
way to go for sustainable energy for um
sustainable energy generation so this
you know the Tesla Mission I think we've
made a lot of progress but still
um it's a lot more ahead
um than SpaceX the goal is uh
it's a it's a big goal but it's we want
to try to make life multi-planetary to
extend life beyond Earth and I think
this is important for a number of
reasons but
um yeah there's the sort of defensive
reason of ensuring that the light of
Consciousness does not go out
um and if I made some of these questions
if I'm going on too long you feel free
to interrupt me but the no no you can
Okay so
um
you know people do ask me you know have
I seen UFOs uh and aliens and that kind
of thing and um I haven't and I think I
would have seen them by now
um so it appears that we might there's
we might be the only Consciousness at
least in this galaxy and
um and if so that's kind of a scary
Prospect because it means that the light
of Consciousness is like a like a tiny
candle in a vast Darkness
and we should do everything we can to
prevent that candle from going out
so yeah
and and so so some of the things so that
means obviously taking the actions to
ensure that Earth is good that Earth is
safe and secure for civilization
um and it I think it also means
extending life beyond Earth
um to other planets in the solar system
and ultimately to other star systems
um and I think that's that's both a sort
of defense of the light of Consciousness
and also
um I think a point of inspiration
because the life cannot just be about
solving
um one problem after another
we need things that Inspire us I mean we
need things that move our hearts
and
that when you wake up in the morning
you're excited to be alive
and being a space-bearing civilization
and making true the things that we see
in the good science fiction movies
this is one of the things that I think
can inspire all of humanity just like
the you know when when the
astronauts went to the moon in 69 it was
something that
then they said For All Mankind you know
and it really was something you say to
any human on earth what's the what is it
what's like
the most amazing thing that Humanity has
ever done a lot of at least one of those
things would be we went to the moon you
know and so you want to have these
inspiring things that make you excited
to be alive and excited about the future
um
yeah and you you had those thoughts and
dreams when you are a kid though this
came much later on
well I didn't think I would be doing
these things as a kid
um that's for sure I was interested in
technology I've read a lot of books
so
I was obviously interested in science I
mean this is hardly going to be
surprising I was interested in science
fiction and Technology you have to tell
the truth because
yeah my mom's right there she can call
me out on this if it's not not accurate
but
um so
I guess the the thing that was
Maybe
most significant from a philosophical
standpoint was that when I was about
maybe 12 or 13 I had somewhat of an
existential crisis where I was like I
was like what what is the meaning of
Life Is Life just meaningless why are we
here what does it all mean
and um
and I read a lot of books on religion
and philosophy and um and then
ultimately the you know I read this book
Hitchhikers Guide to the Galaxy which is
great
um and in that book that book is really
a philosophy book that's disguised as
humor and the point that Douglas Adams
makes is that the the real difficulties
understanding what questions to ask
about the answer that is the universe
and that we that that really we want to
we want to have it's it's essentially if
it's like a philosophy of curiosity
of of saying well what can we do to find
out more about
the the nature of the universe and um
and the meaning of life and so
that's that's the sort of foundational
element and then from there you say okay
well if we want to find out meaning of
life we have to expand the scope and
scale of Consciousness we have to go out
there and we explore the Stars to know
what questions to ask about the universe
and understand the universe and that's
that's my core philosophy
um
and and so from that it was like well we
have to make sure that uh Earth is good
so we have to have sustainable energy
um we um we want to build technology to
travel beyond Earth
and
that's it's from that sort of core
philosophy that these companies uh arise
in most cases
um they can say how does Twitter help
with that
[Laughter]
I would like to go back to Earth sure
and to the various Enterprises that you
contributed to Korea or co-created or
created let's start with PayPal
so a very impressive company do you
regret to have sold it
um I I think
in retrospect I think it was it was good
to have that that the company was
acquired by eBay
um because there was so much talent at
PayPal and that Talent subsequently went
on to create many other companies
um so uh YouTube for example was created
by two people that worked at at PayPal
um
uh we had there was a LinkedIn was
created from from PayPal there was Yelp
there was many other companies
um yeah yeah very impressive
yeah so and then if I'd been still
working on PayPal then there wouldn't be
you know Tesla would not be in its
current form and and SpaceX wouldn't
exist
yes so and yes I guess a short answer
yes
short-term sorry that um yes
yeah yeah but now within you would have
loved to keep it again
well there is I think
the potential to do something
that is um
uh bigger than PayPal
this is sort of like the X the sort of
everything app kind of thing so I
I think it's it's somewhat poetic like
we're trying to get
good finish a task that was started
about 24 years ago
um
I think it's I think we it's going to be
useful at X Twitter is going to be just
a very useful thing
um and hopefully something that is a
positive force for civilization
and moving to Tesla and I have
through one of our operation don't the
first advertising campaign for the
electric car of GM that was at the end
of the 90s
so can you explain why
GM and other car manufacturers have not
created Tesla and why Tesla is
successful
what is the difference
um
you're talking about the ev1 basically
the ev1 car that was so uh General
Motors actually did come out with this
uh electric vehicle one ev1 and uh yes
you remember if you want yes yeah
um and uh actually so I thought when
that came out of 97 yeah that sounds
about right yeah um I would have I
expected there would be an ev2 EV3 and
so forth and if they've done that
actually there would be no need for
Tesla
um but
um
for reasons that that aren't clear they
GM recalled all of the EV ones even from
customers that really wanted to keep the
cars they recalled the cars and they
crushed them in a junkyard
and
the the it was it still blows my mind
that they did this because
the the people who had the EV ones they
love the cost so much they held a
candlelit vigil at the junkyard where
the cars were crushed
okay like it was
like like someone was getting killed you
know like
and it's like
if somebody is holding a candle at vigil
for them because they love your product
so much maybe you should make more of it
you know I mean
it's like pretty rare
for Catholic vigils to be helpful
products so I I don't understand why
they didn't do more they should have and
they would be the leader in electric
vehicles today but they didn't they
didn't and so there was a need for Tesla
because the you know at the time of
starting Tesla there were no electric
vehicles being made
um and they were so the big car
companies were not making electric
vehicles there were no startups that we
were aware of making electric vehicles
so it's like well we should try and um
I mean in the case of both Tesla and
SpaceX I thought the chance of success
was maybe 10 so I just felt like I
thought it would be successful I thought
it would fail
hey good listen and now moving to the
kids dream which is to become an
astronaut and not to bid Rockets how you
move from the idea that every child has
I would be natural to I would do
reusable Rockets
yeah
um
you forgot no I I'm trying to compress
the story so that they're not too long
um
because the story is actually quite long
because I didn't start out wanting to do
the Rockets I at first I was going to do
this
um philanthropic Mission to Mars called
Mars Oasis and then as I started
investigating
um
the what it would take to launch this
Mission to Mars just a little Greenhouse
basically
it was intended to inspire the public
and I started understanding more about
the what Rockets could be used I
actually went to Russia a few times to
try to buy some of their nuclear
missiles
minus the nuclear minus the nuke
um that's extra
um
so that was pretty wild being in Russia
in 2001
negotiating to buy it
two of their biggest missiles
but but it became clear that the
um
and unless there was a something new
with rockets there were that that was
the fundamental issue the cost of access
to space was the fundamental issue so it
wasn't a it wasn't a question of trying
to increase the Public's desire Public's
desire for space and exploration is very
high but there needs to be a means there
needs to be a way
um
and uh there needs to be a radical
Improvement in the cost of access to
Auburn
um
so
I was like okay well I'm going to try
starting a rocket company and see if
it's successful but I like I said I I
told people at the time because because
people would say to me just tell me this
joke of like what's the fast you know
what what what's the
you know how do you go from
sorry
um sorry I'm getting a little hot under
the collar here
um I think a lot of people are
um so
they'll say what's the fastest way to
make us a small fortune in the rocket
industry in it and the punch line is you
start with a large one
so
you know it was It was a
tough going for a while our first three
launches failed fortunately the fourth
one succeeded if the fourth one had not
succeeded SpaceX would not exist so it
was a very close call
fast forward you created or you
co-created open AI yes uh chat GPT has
been incredibly success incredibly
successful it's the the fastest growing
ever
story and
after having created
open AI suddenly you say oh we should
have a pause
some people say oh it's because he has
not done it
well I mean I didn't think anyone would
actually agree to the pause but I
thought just for the record I just want
to say I think we should pause I don't
think that uh
why do you want to should pose
well I think there's there's a real
danger for digital super intelligence uh
having negative consequences and so if
we are I'm not careful with
creating artificial general intelligence
we could have potentially a catastrophic
outcome
so now I think there's a range of
possibilities I think the most likely
outcome is positive for AI but it but
that's not every possible outcome so we
need to minimize the probability that
something will go wrong with digital
super intelligence
yes
so I'm in favor of AI regulation because
I think Advanced AI is a risk to the
public and anything that's risked to the
public there needs to be some kind of
referee that referee is the regulator
and so I think that's that's my strong
recommendation is to have some
regulation for AI
some regulation for AI yes which is what
you want also for Twitter
I'm not sure
regulation I guess there's plenty of
plenty of regulators
sure thank you so speaking about Twitter
you you have made a big bet
yeah on Twitter
you said it a few minutes ago that you
paid too much
yes yes
uh and you are now going on to Twitter
2.0 or 3.0
which I understand it's a full-scale
reinvention of the company
uh yeah so we're both in the company
very rapidly again
the company is changing quite
dramatically there are a lot of
controvers about Twitter so I have in
fact three very quick question the first
one is why have you decided to acquire
it
the second is what was wrong at Twitter
to make you acting and the last one is
not the last last of the three because
there are many other questions is why do
you believe that you would be successful
and you will be well thanks
um I can imagine I can't imagine that
you will not be well thanks
um
so
well obviously I was on Twitter as a
major user and even before the
acquisition
um closed my my Twitter account was the
most interactive with account in the
world so
my I guess I'll be I'm pretty closely
attuned to what's going on with Twitter
you know I get a feel for how is it
shifting one way or the other and uh
generally I was concerned that
Twitter was having a negative effect on
civilization that was having a corrosive
effect on civil society and um and so
that you know anything that undermines
uh civilization I think is not good and
you know go back to my point of like we
need to do everything possible to
support civilization and move it in a
positive direction and and I felt that
it would that Twitter was kept moving
more and more in a negative Direction
and my hope and aspiration was to change
that and have it be a positive force for
civilization
it is not perceived like this
before are very happy to listen to that
approach but it the perception is very
different
well I think it depends on I mean I
think if if somebody is a regular
Twitter user I think they most people
would say that their experience has
improved
um we've we've gotten rid of
um
uh 90 of the Bots and the scams and and
the various bad things that were
happening
um we've
gotten rid of now at this point I think
95 of the child exploitation material
that was on Twitter which was a shock to
see the amount of that that was really
terrible some of that had been going on
for 10 years and no action
so
I think we've done a lot of good on that
respect
um
and um
and then I think you know we've also
done things like we we have open sourced
the algorithm so we're trying to be as
transparent as possible so Twitter is
the only social media company where you
can see the actual code of the algorithm
so it's not like some secret Black Box
um
I mean the the the way to build trust is
that waitable trust is not take my word
for it it's let's let's show you exactly
how it works and full transparency and
um
and and we're also going to be showing
like if your account is in any way
affected by the Twitter system you can
see it clearly
um and uh just you know moving into I
think a good direction
um
I think the recommendation algorithm I
don't want to go on too long for Twitter
but I think it's I think it's actually
uh quite good and that those are on who
are on the Twitter system I think
generally think it's good
um the you know we are seeing all-time
highs in usage so at least you know for
the public out there they are using the
system more
um
so we're seeing a pretty significant
week over week growth in in usage
um
so
the you know the public is speaking with
their time and if they're putting their
time on on Twitter that's a very good
signal
um so that's that's very positive
um
what would you say to
advertisers who left Twitter
to convince them to come back
yeah actually I should say that
um maybe with a few exceptions almost
all the advertisers have said that
they've either come back or they said
they will come back so actually
I feel pretty pretty optimistic about
the future
um and um yeah so you know we really
at this point I believe
actually I'm not aware of any Advertiser
that is uh either they've either come
back or they said they'll come back I'm
not aware of any exceptions they're
probably a few exceptions but overall I
think it's uh it's very positive
good so we will have now a broader
conversation we will ask
Crystal Edmond from
Orange the CEO of orange to join us as
well as
entrepreneur from lvmh and asmita dubei
from uh loyal we have to move in order
that they add a chair so come here
[Applause]
why they are arranging
there is uh yes yes yes yes
there is one question yeah that I would
like to
[Applause]
take care
so finally we are all together again so
I I had another question but I will save
it for later and I will give the floor
to Crystal Crystal the man who is the
CEO of orange and she is very much
excited about putting some harsh
difficult question to you
let's go
Twitter
yeah
and open debates that maybe were not
possible before that sure now there's
also another side of it which is that
be some
information fake news
news fake news what that's crazy
you believe that wait how do I know this
is real
now the question is and actually I think
there's a flip side you need to social
networks and there's a Code of Conduct
that the EU has proposed to this
information okay recently
we decided to walk away from it
so is this um because we don't
like that before
moderated and actually using printable
on the content cooperation so just what
are your thoughts on that
well I'm generally a fan of
um that we should have a free speech as
much as possible as much as is allowed
by the laws of any country so
um you know I think that
you know say
for France we should
um allow things that are allowed by law
and if the people are want the laws to
be different then pass a different law
and will adhere to that law but but
report for Twitter to go beyond the law
that you know that doesn't seem quite
right to me I think we want to allow the
people to express themselves
um and and really if you have to say
when does Free Speech matter Free Speech
matters and it's only relevant if if
people are allowed to say things that
you don't like because otherwise it's
not free speech
um and and I would I would take that if
if somebody says something you know
potentially offensive
but that's that's actually okay now now
we're not going to promote those you
know offensive uh tweets but uh but I
think people should be able to say
things
because the alternative is censorship
and then and frankly I think if you go
down the censorship route it's only a
matter of time before censorship is
turned upon you
so that's why it's important
um you know for in the US you've got the
first amendment of freedom of speech
amendment and he said like why did they
do that that's because why did they pass
that Amendment it was because they were
not able to say what they wanted to say
in the countries that they came from
and they wanted to make sure that they
could say what they wanted to say so I
believe in Freedom for the people uh to
say things and that even if somebody
said that it's actually in some ways a
sign of Health if people are able to if
someone you don't like is able to say
something you don't like
rather than try to suppress that you say
like you know what that's a good sign
because
that means I can say things and that
person will not like what I say but I
can still say it and that's a really big
deal
[Applause]
especially in this country I mean
freedom of speech that's something
that's very I mean at the core of our
values but now if we look at young
people and being in the digital field
and we provide Digital Services that
people use there's also a move towards
cyber bullying and harassment which I
think we all it's also our role to
educate young people on how to use the
technology and make sure that because
some behaviors I mean on Twitter or
other social networks can actually have
devastating effects on
uh is Twitter doing something about it
or would you be willing
other players actually at Orange we do a
lot in that space sure
I I mean that's true
I think I think you know Twitter is for
sure willing to engage with others
um and like as I said the overarching
goal is to have Twitter be a force a
positive force for civilization and
um
you know so and and and if if you're on
the platform and you're being harassed
or bullied or whatever obviously that's
a negative experience
um so
um so you know what we're doing is it's
we call it sort of
freedom of speech but not freedom of
reach uh which is that if you yes you
can say offensive things but then your
content is going to get down rated so if
you're a jerk you your reach will drop
so yeah I think that's the right thing
and
also and I don't know if you will be
competing with the real to launch the
future fragrance for Elon Musk and that
the brand so you have to compete very
hard but maybe
you I know that you had already the
lunch but there is never the Deezer so
you can put your question all right
first of all in the name of um
it's great to have you on welcome
so change of subjects from Twitter
um at lvmh our oldest missile is called
claudi Lombre I saw you enjoyed good
wine yeah
um it's 650 years old wow
Louis Vuitton was founded in 1854.
our most ancient American Maison Tiffany
was founded in 1837.
the sum of the years of existence of all
are Maison at lvmh is
8393 years old wow
Tesla is a teenager right yes yes 19 19
years old yeah and its market cap is
already higher than lvmh
security question of age
yeah so so first question first question
how much longer are you going to make us
look so bad
second question more serious do you feel
the creation of value is more
challenging
in traditional or innovative business
well first of all it's honor to be here
and and speak with you so thanks for
having me
you know evaluations are are a strange
thing because
um you know sometimes I've said hey I
think the stock price is too high at
Tesla and then the stock price goes up
I'm like okay
um so if you you tweet is it going up or
down no the crazy thing I mean when I've
created I think the stock price is too
high almost always it goes up
so
I don't know it's strange thing so I I
guess in the case of Chancellor if the
the really the the value of the company
is primarily
uh on the basis of autonomy so uh in my
opinion
um because if you look at our total
vehicle output it's um it'll be almost 2
million Vehicles this this year or
something like that
um but that's that's still only two
percent of total vehicle production so
then why is our market cap so high and
it's because the potential for autonomy
um is uh that the value of autonomy is
so high
um that even
even if you have a discounted percentage
probability of autonomy happening that
is still incredibly valuable so the
average passenger car is used only about
10 hours a week so an average of about
one and a half hours a day but if you
have an autonomous Robo taxi the utility
might be 50 or 60 hours a week out of
168 hours so now you've got a vehicle
that costs the same but has five times
the utility
so it's so gigantic a change that that's
really I think
uh the main driver of our value
and although I've said this before I
think we will solve autonomy soon
did you expect that the Tesla will be at
this level of market cap no I did not
expect Tesla would be at this level but
yeah because this is just extraordinary
uh unfair by the way I mean I don't set
the price so yeah you don't said are you
just another quick question
um I tried mid-journey the other day
yeah returning is amazing right and and
I asked the software to make a Louis
Vuitton advertising campaign with only
two words so here it's a bad question
for you Maurice right
if if you are if you want to put me out
of a job that was my question do you
feel
this advertising production industry is
going to be threatened by AI
be careful
not at all
it's totally safe
[Laughter]
I mean AI is definitely going to be a
massive disruptive course I mean it AI
is probably the the most disruptive
technology ever
I mean the crazy thing is that you know
the the advantage that humans have is
that uh we're smarter than other
creatures like if we got into a fight
with the gorilla the gorilla would
definitely win
um but we're smart so
but now for the first time there's going
to be something that is smarter than the
smartest human
like way smarter than the smartest human
and as you can see from a journey the
art that AI can create is incredible
it's so beautiful and it does it you
know within seconds
so
we're at I mean I think
you know there's that sort of saying may
you live in interesting times which I
think is like not exactly a good thing
sometimes but but we actually live I
think we live in the most interesting of
times
um the Advent of AI and I actually
thought to myself at one point like
uh should you know do I would I really
want to be alive at this point like
let's say that there is some AI
Armageddon
um that happens some sort of AI
apocalypse
I think I would still be want to be
alive at this time to see it
and hopefully you know hopefully not not
create cause it
um
but
it's it's just a I think we live in an
extremely interesting time you know um
because the things that you see AI being
able to do now it's going to do much
more with each passing year
cars will absolutely drive themselves
better than any person could drive
um
we'll have humanoid robots
like so Tesla's developing a humanoid
robot
we call it the T800 it's a yeah some
people get that joke
[Laughter]
it's a Terminator
um so we've done tweet that yeah
um but if you like to say what isn't
what is an economy an economy is GDP per
capita times Capital now what happens if
you don't actually have a limit on
Capital if you have an unlimited number
of uh
sort of people or robots
it's not it's not clear what meaning an
economy has at that point because you
have an unlimited economy effectively
um so so like on the good side the plus
side of AI is that I think we are
heading for an age of abundance
um where any goods and services that you
want
you can just have
um
so that's that's the that's the the
positive side of of of AI future is an
age of abundance
inside I must say that we are using AI
since many years and it is helping us a
great deal and this is a tool that we
are already using and I think it will be
helping us to do even faster some very
good ad it will be probably a long time
before they replace the creative minds
uh asmita maybe you have an opinion on
that and maybe you can asmita is the CDO
of L'Oreal and she she knows a lot about
digital so maybe you can tell us a
little bit about advertising and Ai and
put your question to Elan so I'll pick
up from advertising and from what you
said before about Twitter so now we know
that Twitter is expensive and we know
that it aims to have free speech
the question I have is about winning the
advertiser's trust to be a preferred
social media platform in the current
context where
the expected Revenue you know in 2023 is
lower than 2022 you have brought in new
leadership Linda so I wanted to know
that how
time the support the freedom because
she's an advertising expert so so will
she be able to manage the situation and
how
yeah I I think I think I think Linda's
great
um so I think Linda's gonna do uh
amazing things for for Twitter and
obviously understands where advertisers
are coming from very deeply
understands the concerns that
advertisers have and I think we'll do a
great job in addressing those concerns
um
you know a key part is
um you know let me say like if you're an
Advertiser what content do you want to
appear next to and depending upon what
Advertiser you know the sensitivity of
the brand
um if you're for example say Disney and
you're advertising a children's movie
then you want to have you know all ages
content you know
um and by the way Disney is one of our
biggest advertisers so um
so so it's really about just making sure
that the content adjacency matches uh
what a brand is comfortable with
and then there's some cases where the
the content is like you know there's not
going to be any advertising because
nobody wants to advertise next to it and
that's going to be some of the more
controversial stuff
um yeah
about content you have just made the
announcement that there will be ad
Revenue sharing for creators yes yeah
and that has a condition it will be done
when they are verified Blue Tick
creators and the advertising is to
verify Blue Tick users yes now if with
that how does that impact your focus on
subscription revenues because to be blue
take uh you know there's a subscription
versus advertising revenues Focus
foreign
yeah so a big part of like when you say
like say how many Impressions does
something get uh you say like well were
those Impressions real or not real you
know was it uh you know a computer just
what running a hundred thousand fake
accounts because that obviously doesn't
count because the computer's not going
to buy anything
um so that's why our focus is on on
verified users because
we are admittedly conflating
verification and subscription uh at
Twitter so you could say like verified
subscriber or something like that
that's not it's not possible to game
that so you know it's real you know it's
solid and you know it's not a computer
um so that's why it's that that's why
we're focused on that
um is to ensure the authenticity of the
views and that it really uh that real
people are seeing uh what's going on I
mean the sheer amount of of Bot and scam
and spam activity in social media is
insane
um and we're talking about AI it's very
obvious that especially with today's AI
the computers can pass every like are
you a human test in fact I think they
can pass all your human tests better
than a human
you know sort of you say like identify a
traffic light or something like that
okay let me tell you Tesla can identify
a traffic life so if we're you know and
but even like open source uh AI stuff
right now can pass all of the the human
tests so you have to have something that
there's better authentication than than
that yeah
yeah I think that um
confidence and trust is something which
we lose fast and that we regain slowly
uh I have no doubt personally that
Twitter will gain back the trust
provided that you do the right thing and
I'm sure that you will do the right
thing so this uh something which is
probably just a hiccup in the time but
you need to do the writing and I'm sure
that
you you will do it I have
two small questions one which is
regarding Ukraine you have
uh help enormously Ukraine yeah at the
beginning with starlings and I think we
owe you a lot because without access
to internet and without access to
communication the war would have been
finished
what is your take on that experience
yeah that was a
I mean that whole situation is very
complex
um no kidding yeah it's really really
um
as you point out starlink did play a
pivotal role
um because Russia had actually taken out
all of the satellite Communications and
all of the ground Communications except
for starlink was the only one that was
still operating
um and and even today it is still the
only one that is effective at the front
lines and uh stalling today is the
backbone of the Ukrainian military
Communications
so
you know I thought it was important to
help out
um
and um
but I but I do I do hope for some kind
of resolution
soon because I I think it's it's
terribly sad
that that's the flower of the Youth of
Ukraine and Russia uh who don't want to
be there
that they're dying in trenches right now
and I sure hope we can figure out some
means to pee soon
[Applause]
the last question is going back to this
crowd you have a lot of startups you
have a lot of young people who want to
be successful
what are the two or three pieces of
advice that you would give them well you
have a question over there yes
do we have a microphone because Elon has
accepted
to take question from the floor
shout out
a a microphone
hey go you have the mic you go
yes okay
I don't know why you got the mic but
please go
identified short question
sure
electric cars obviously okay yeah yeah
um okay yeah give them my bike
yeah yeah
uh I mean uh me and Mario should get a
room basically
I I love Mars
okay
no no no no now I want that to give the
mic sorry guys
uh
there okay so what's the question what
is the question my name is
co-founder and CEO at click out we make
AI tiny so Tesla is one of our Target I
would love to work with you Ellen and my
husband is actually ex movie line who
has very like the infrastructure and
okay
okay sure oh
[Applause]
okay
one last question
guys whatever yeah okay however long you
want to do it no no
yeah totally crazy
yeah
[Music]
we are working on the mental health to
help people to go to Mars actually sure
that's great
it's relevant mental health for Humanity
well I think I think you'd want to have
a very good mental health on a trip to
Mars make sure everyone's sane because
you don't want someone opening at the
airlock in the middle of the night
um
so I think sanity is very important uh
if you're going to Mars
please we're just gonna just descend
into chaos
I just take it
[Music]
okay you would get okay and easy
okay okay now thank you sir I'm
Nathaniel Ackerman from okay I I think
we're gonna just it's gonna be chaos can
you hear me
foreign
and
[Music]
um you know that there have been many
amendments due to llm deployment
do you think uh how can we integrate the
use and actual use of this llm in a
non-controlled way in the the current
discussion
translation
thank you
safe llm use okay just a second
no please it will answer the question it
wasn't about safe safety and llms or
sorry I didn't hear the whole question
it's like a safe application of llms or
or what is it
the regulations
integrates the
the llm
okay and protect us from the Jews and
those things
okay
sure okay when the regulation has been
created llm didn't exist so what would
be your suggestion regarding regulating
llms well I think more broadly um there
should be
um
regulatory insight into llms and and
really any other form of AI I mean
there's I'm not sure I I don't think LMS
are the ultimate form of AI
um I mean there's sort of inside joke on
AI of like who do you think will be the
American president in 2032 diffusion or
Transformers
those are inside jokes but yeah it's
like what does that mean
um but that like might be a real it
might be real
um so yeah
so we will have the dresses here the two
latest questions one here and one in
that region so go ahead thank you
see it off
[Music]
I mean no if we don't listen to the
question we will not be able to continue
well
[Music]
and we have um
which is the 13 under
my question is what business young
people should focus on
uh sure
[Applause]
well I think generally I think it's
important to focus on something
go ahead sorry I think
um you want to focus on something that
you are personally passionate about that
you personally care about
um it's very hard to be motivated for a
product that you don't really feel
strongly about
um and it doesn't have to be high-tech
it could be in any in any field it's
just it's got to be a product that you
feel is is really needs to be there that
that and something that you personally
love
um
and I would listen to your instincts on
on you know do do you love this product
or service
um because it's kind of impossible to
know what do other people love but if
you love it that's a good sign
um and um and that could that could be
small to large any kind of any field
it's it doesn't have to be high tech but
if if you don't love if you if you don't
really love the product that you're
making if you can't like a good test
would be that you can't wait for this
product to be on the market
and if that's the case you're you're
going in the right direction
great uh
the last question we have
we have a friend
I don't know
we have a French saying which is
wait
[Applause]
no no you you another kid
foreign
[Applause]
he's asking foreign
that you will see your link is going to
be a fairly slow process because
anything that's done in humans it's very
slow so sometimes people think that this
suddenly we're going to be tripping
everyone's head and then before they
know it everyone's connected to the
internet and then we're in trouble with
your brain
um so it's going to happen very slowly
hopefully later this year we'll do our
first uh human device implantation and
this will be for someone that has sort
of tetraplegic quadriplegic does not
have it has lost the connection from
their their brain to their body and we
think we should be able to that person
will be able to
communicate uh as fast as someone who
has a fully functional body
um so that's going to be a big deal and
we and we see a path beyond that to
actually transfer the signals from the
motor cortex of the brain to pass the
injury in the spinal cord and actually
enable someone's body to be used again
so
um
essentially shunting the signals past
the broken point
and and restore potentially full full
body
um
use to someone that has completely lost
the connection and I mean you can
imagine like if say Stephen Hawking were
alive today what a profound change that
would be
um and um so that's our first
application and uh if uh it's looking
like that the first case will be later
this year
so yeah
fantastic
no
I would like
a very very warm Rose of Applause to
Elon Musk
[Applause]
okay thank you thank you oh oh thank you
I just want to say you guys are great
you guys are I mean it's it's so
inspiring to see so much energy and so
much positive energy uh in the room so
uh this is very inspiring for the future
thank you
okay thank you
it's gonna be crazy
[Music]